okay hello everybody uh welcome to
today's webinar on elastic blast this is
peter cooper from ncbi um i'm going to
introduce tom madden who's going to be
your speaker today
and so with that i'm going to turn this
over to tom madden who's the blast lead
and he's going to talk about elastic
blast take it away tom
hi this is tom madden i'm the offering
lead for blast at the ncbi today i'm
going to tell you about a project i'm
really excited about it's called elastic
blast and it lets you run your blast
searches with minimal effort on the
cloud
so my main emphasis today will be on
what elastic blast can do for you
so this is not supposed to be tutorial
on how to run it
we have pretty good documentation on
that and i'll point you to that
documentation at the end of the webinar
first let's go over the agenda to start
i'll give you a bit of an introduction
and set some context
then i'll do a demo of elastic blast
that's right a live demo
next i'll show you the range of searches
elastic blasts can do
how quickly it can do those
and what those cost
also we'll talk about minimizing costs
and how you can try elastic blast out
for free
then i'll talk about what elastic blast
does for you to make using the cloud
easier
finally we'll discuss resources that can
help you
okay so first what is blast briefly
blast compares dna or protein sequences
to a database of dna or protein
sequences
if necessary it translates the dna into
protein for the comparison
we have a webpage an ncbi webpage for
blast a command line suite of tools we
call blast plus and some cloud products
so elastic blast is built on top of the
blast plus command line suite
this is my one sentence description of
elastic blast
here i say that elastic blast is a cloud
native package
meaning
that we've used tools like kubernetes
or aws batch that are maintained by the
cloud provider as well as things like
cloud buckets which is just an area on
your on the cloud you can store files in
we use the buckets to store
your queries results and other files
we've also written some blast specific
software to make the cloud easier to use
with elastic blast
so this is a list of reasons to use
elastic blast
there are a lot of reasons
i think but i want to emphasize here
that elastic blast
makes it relatively simple to run your
blast searches on the cloud and do it
efficiently
it can work with both smaller sets of
queries and very large ones and do that
quickly
okay so at this point i'm going to
switch to a live demo and i guess i just
like to live dangerously
okay so in this demo i'll look at a set
of proteins from a wgs or whole genome
shotgun
woodchuck project that are mostly
labeled as hypothetical meaning that we
don't really know what they are
and i'm going to search them against
high quality refseq select protein
database i'm also going to limit that
search taxonomically to mouse
to do that i first need a configuration
file for elastic class
and i'll show you that to you right now
okay the configuration file has three
sections
um well actually let me step back so as
i mentioned we have pretty good
documentation and tutorials that walk
you through your first search so don't
sweat all these details right now i'm
just gonna just
sit back and absorb them
okay so the configuration file has three
sections the top one cloud provider
which i just highlighted
just provides some information about
where this is run
in this case it
just lists the aws region us-e-1
and there's really not much to do there
in the second section
the cluster one
this is where you can put in information
about the number of instances you want
in other cluster specific information
in this case i've asked for eight
machines
or nodes
and also to run this as a spot instance
which is what this preemptable means
spot instance just means that you'll be
running a little bit cheaper price and
i'm going to come back and talk about
that the details about that later so
don't sweat the details exactly right
now
finally the third section has blast
specific information
and so first the program is blastp
which compares a protein query to a
protein database
the database is listed as refseq select
prote
this is a high quality carefully curated
database produced at the nci
for the queries
we have a path to a cloud bucket on aws
and this is basically disk space you can
use to store files pretty cheaply and so
i just have the fasta files up in this
cloud bucket
the results also go into a cloud bucket
this is where i'll find them when the
search is done
and then so finally the blast options
and i put down here task blastp dash
fast which is just a means that i want
blastp to run in a faster mode is
normally
this is really what you should be
running
i've set the expect value pretty low
meaning i'm going to look for matches
that i think are really significant
so here you also see the out format
option 7
and so what this does
this is will produce tabular output that
includes
some standard fields
the length
of the query and the database sequences
not the length of the alignment but the
length of the actual sequences
the query coverage per subject sequence
the tax id
of the match which is just a and the tax
id is just a
an integer um
and every node and
the ncbi tax element tree has a tax id
assigned to it
um
as well as the scientific name
so finally at the end here and this this
actually wraps around it says tax ids
1090.
1090 is the tax id for mouse so i'm
actually going to limit my searches to
just mouse
so one thing i want to do before i
run this is i want to take a check of
what version of elastic blast i have
installed here
so here it is plastic blast
0.2.2 which is the latest version
um elastic blast is pretty new
and so we're updating it as issues um
get reported to us so i always suggest
using the latest version and not letting
that lag
so now i can
want to sub
submit my search
and i'm just going to copy and paste
here so that you don't have to watch me
type
um so i execute elastic blast with the
submit command and you see their elastic
blast
and then the keyword submit token submit
and then config in this dash dash config
parameter to point to this um
would shook underscore mouse
configuration file that we just looked
at
and so i'll hit return
and this takes a minute
to set up
this takes a few minutes to return as it
waits for resources to be prepared
and then the um
the whole search takes about 20 minutes
so we're going to look at some results i
prepared earlier
and actually i'd like to let this return
so you also see some messages here
that will tell you that you know that
basically you can ignore these
there's something about the aws limit
checker
something about gp2
none of this is really that important
um
in this case
okay so i'm going to put this in the
background
um so i can get on and i'm going to kind
of look at the
results that had been
that i
produced earlier
and so i'm just first of all i'm going
to make a directory here and cd into it
and this directory is just the name of
the um
wgs project
and that's pretty yellow for people
familiar with linux that's pretty
standard
so this next part is a little bit
trickier
aws has a command line interface and gcp
has something similar um and in a way
they they kind of mimic linux um if you
haven't seen them before
they look kind of familiar to linux like
this one here aws s3 s3 is what aws
calls for buckets
and then copy just like you would have
copy and so it's going to copy the
results
of what's in this bucket and do it
recursively and to the current directory
so let me do that
and so
it happens pretty quickly and you'll see
that there are um
you see there are a lot of files here
and this has to do with how elastic
blast processes the queries
and so let me just do an ls here
and so the first thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to um
run this g unzip command to
simply put all the files together
into a
something a file called woodchuck
underscore mouse.tab so this is
basically dnz c
is gonna
concatenate all the contents of those
files into this one
tabular file
so we can take a look at the um
the tabular file now and so you're going
to see
some lines start with a hash mark
and those are just additional data that
we can ignore right now
and if i go down here a bit
so here you're going to see a number of
significant matches you know and so this
is the um
the query id this is the database
you know id the database sequence um and
there's a whole bunch of fields here um
you know this is 94 identity and the
lengthy alignment is some
700 residues and so this is this is kind
of going on here and you don't really
need um so you could look at this but
really this tabular output is more meant
to be processed um with some sort of
script
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to um i wrote a
quick python script
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to execute the script
and but before i do that let me tell you
a little bit about um
what the script is supposed to do
um so i've written a script to um
look for alignments that show at least
50 identity and that's one of these
fields up here that you can see
the query in the database sequences are
about supposed to be about the same
length and since i asked for that
information to be printed i can
calculate that also
and also that 90 of the query is covered
by database sequence
and so let me hit return here
and so running the script i see
my alignments that meet
um
my cutoff and that they're just
streaming by
um
so i'm not saying no i'm not going to
say that this is the best way to filter
alignments i'm just saying you can do it
however you want and
just kind of demonstrating that
and also say that this tabular output is
something that you can produce
is actually produced by the blast plus
executables that underlie elastic blast
so you could do this
with a standalone blast plus command
line
um
you could also do it with elastic blast
um and really this tabular output is
very flexible you can get lots of
different fields in there you can even
get sequence in here
okay so now that i've done that let's um
the demo has worked um without incident
apparently so let's go back to the um
powerpoint slides
okay so in december i tried out an
elastic blast run from my personal gcp
or google cloud platform account it was
the example in our quick start which is
the first search we suggest people do
a few days later
the bill arrived via gmail well of
course but you know
as you can see it cost all of 1.94
to run those blast searches on the cloud
i thought you know cool this is cheaper
than coffee
you know it turns out i was wrong you
can get a basic tall coffee at starbucks
for 1.90 or so
so this statement only applies to grande
or larger i just
want to make sure that you know i have
this right
okay um despair not though
next i'll talk about how you can run the
search with mechanisms that allow you to
pay a fraction the full price
i don't want anybody have to give up the
coffee you know that's generally not a
good thing
um
next slide here is instances at less
than full price so both aws and gcp have
met have a mechanism where you can bid
on instances at less than full price and
use them at that price if your bid
succeeds
with aws they are called spot instances
and the rate varies between 10 and 100
of full price i did a few runs last week
and ended up with prices about one third
of full price but like i said this may
vary
um with gcp
they are called preemptable instances
and go for about 20 of full price
caveat is instances may not always be
available right away
um elastic blast will use spot or
preemptable instances if you asked yet
to do so so that makes it easy and
you might recall i had simply put that
in the config file when i did my run i
said pre use preemptable
okay so finally here are some example
runs
now my idea here is to show you a sample
of different searches that you can do
with elastiglass that's why i print i'm
presenting a range of searches i've
listed the size of the query and
database how many cpus were used the
time to run and the cost
i have searches done at both gcp and aws
that's in the provider column here
and i'm going to go through these rows
and we'll have a red diamond
to the left the row i'm discussing like
this for the top rail so in the top row
we're finding conserved domains for 3.4
billion bases of human gunmen a genome
yes i did say 3.4 billion with a b
and for this i brought up
132 cpu instances and got the results a
little more than just two hours two
hours and fifteen minutes
um it would have taken more than four
days just running this with 32 threads
on a single machine
the run the whole cost of the run was
270 dollars
but it could be less with preemptable
instances
okay the second row is a quick start run
i mentioned earlier so we have pretty
good instructions on running the quick
start at
aws and gcp in our documentation
and this is the first search we suggest
to you on you can try it right after
this webinar if you want
and as you can see again it takes about
30 minutes
cost was
at gcp was a dollar ninety four
preemptable costs should be about 38
cents
the third row is a search against nt
which is or the nucleotide collection
which is the single most used nucleotide
database at the ncbi it's not small at
662 billion bases
the query is also
relatively large at 82 million bases
and it's a collection of all hepatitis
sequences i pulled out of nt about two
years ago
and this can run for under five dollars
if you use
spot instances
and at this configuration at this
configuration it takes about an hour and
a half to run
and i probably could have actually added
more cpus and run this a little bit
faster
okay so the fourth row is the search of
the refseq select database limited
amount sequences
elastic blast supports taxonomic
limitations
so it's not a problem to limit to mouse
and this looks familiar because it's the
example i did in the demo
as you can see runtime is about 21
minutes um three dollars and 30 cents
for the
cost at
real cost to run and as a spot instance
it could run about 94 seconds and so
um and the number of cpu uses 128.
and so finally
least but not last
the last row is a search of some
proteins against the popular nr or
non-redundant database
um this run costs about two dollars
here
and could run in 48 minutes um
it's 65 cents as a spot instance and
i'll just actually add that the nr
database is actually pretty large it's
about 175 billion residues um this is
more kind of a smallish query um
at only 57 000 letters at least smallish
by
elastic blast standards
okay some notes on where these cost
estimates come from
um so for the gc
so i did these runs and calculated the
um
the cost based on how long they took to
run
um the gcp preemptables i simply
calculate that as 20 of the full cost
um for the spot instances
i actually did both the um
the full price run and the spot run and
then i'd go and look at what's the cost
of a spot instance
of that of a spot of that spot instance
at that point in time um in aws um gives
you a web page to do that
um
and i'll i have a link to that later on
at the end of the um
at the end of this webinar um and so
these costs these costs basically spot
instance costs were from last week
thursday and friday
okay so i as i mentioned earlier both
gcp and aws have a free tier or free
trial they use different terms to let
you try things out
this is time limited but that time is in
months
there are also limits on resources um
and so we have documentation how about
how to use elastic blast under those
constraints in our documentation and
i've got a link to that at the end of
this presentation
okay so on the right side i have a table
and this table is to start a list of all
the different instances that you can use
at aws and gcp has a similar table
so the good news is that you don't need
to look at the 443 different instances
instance types before you run elastic
blast because elastic blast will do it
for you
now the most important question about
whether an instance will work for blast
is whether it has enough memory
the question then becomes how much
memory do you need to run a blast search
and the answer is that it depends upon
the database
so basically you have to have enough
memory to hold the database in memory
and that determines which instance you
want to use
so to answer this question which
instance you want to use
we've introduced metadata for the blast
databases in json that includes the
memory needed to cache the database
elastic blast then adds more memory to
that amount for the program in os and
finds the smallest instance that will be
able to efficiently run your search now
of course you can still specify a
machine type if you prefer you may just
have to go through a long table
okay so
this is the json metadata for a small
database we provide
at the bottom
you can see bytes to cache
which helps elastic blast pick out an
instance
and bites the cache basically tells
elastiglass or could tell you
how much memory you need then you just
add 10 or 20
and you'll notice that there's also like
a date stamp here
and details about the size
and description
of the database this made the data comes
this metadata comes with all ncbi
provided databases if you use your own
database you can produce the metadata
with a python script that comes with
elastoglass
starting with our 2.13 blast plus
release the meta metadata will get
produced when you build your own
database we expect to
ship 2.13 sometime in march now
okay so some notes on the databases that
we have
the ncbi databases
we host 28 ncbi databases at aws and gcp
elasticblast knows how to find and use
these
these
these databases range from the rest
eukaryotic database down here
with over
a trillion bases down to a much smaller
16s database
as well databases for the human and
mouse gms
okay so here are some links to help you
get started
and i recommend starting with the top
one here
and that will introduce you to lasso
class some cloud concepts and then guide
you to a quick chart to try things out
if you're already familiar with the
cloud concepts of course you can skip
over those
and just read about elastic blast
okay
so this is a list of resources that i've
mentioned throughout the talk
the github page
has the source that is python code for
elastic class you can also open an issue
through github
the second to last link for elastic
blast demos down here
has a script to run elastic blast and
download the files for you so that you
don't have to actually
manually run these aws or gcp command
line interface commands
and we'll probably be adding more demos
to this site
the last link lets you see the current
cost of spot instances at aws
um and i understand that's updated like
every five minutes or so
and most of these other links are pretty
self-explanatory but i invite you to
explore those
finally so let us know how this works
for you
we are we are actually excited to hear
from you um let us know if you find a
problem so we can fix it
and so i've listed the email address
but you can also open so this email
address here um you can also open an
issue on our github page
and so that's it for me and i guess i'll
turn it back to peta right now right
see if there are any questions thanks
tom yeah this is peter again so a couple
of questions tom we were you know in
thinking about costs
you know somebody actually asked me in
the chat can we get it for free and and
i answered in a way that basically the
program's free but what the cloud
instances are not but do you think you
can actually run some of these searches
that you showed on a free on the free
tier
well so the
so you can run elastic blast on the free
tier so the issue is um on gcp for
example they limit you to using eight
cpus at one point in time
um
so i actually tried that out
and i
did actually do a run um i actually had
to
what i did was i had to actually specify
an instance um
that was a little bit smaller than we
normally tell people to use and i also
went for the swiss pro database which is
you know fits well into that instance
and um we actually
have
um
so
right here this link here gcp
trial tips i've documented um what i did
what you need to do to try that out and
yeah so so and like i said this is a
time limit thing but it kind of lets you
get in there and give this a try and i
think it's good for 90 days or something
um and i think actually in aws other
people have actually used their free
tier to try things out
okay um so then
another question um is about
i'll just read it to you because it's
got a lot of detail in it it sounds like
elastic blast as an alternative to
setting up the blast plus executables in
the cloud say with docker is that true
are there programs or options we'd be
missing if you if we use the plastic
blast
um yes it it is a i guess you can think
of it as an alternative it kind of makes
it simpler to set up
um
you know and you could use docker or you
could also
use just the blast plus command line
binaries which um i have an impression a
lot of people do in the cloud because
it's just a linux binary um
we've tried to i think we've included
all the programs we might have a few we
might not have done like
delta blasts and such
there are still some options in elastic
blasts that are missing for example you
can't limit your search by a gi list
this came up recently
you know these are things that actually
could be implemented if we hear back
from people that hey i think elastic
blast is good it works well for me but i
need you to implement this um so really
it's kind of
we're reaching out to people now to know
um
is this useful for you and what would
make it more useful for you so so let us
know
so it is a it's an alternative to the
regular blast plus executables but
they're just a few options that are not
supported basically yeah and it's
actually to be clear it's actually a
wrapper over the um the blast plus
executable so it's actually not that
difficult for us to
add things we just need to um
make the time for it
okay um another question is when you use
these preemptable instances
it's possible that
if i understand how that works
it's possible that the cloud provider
could basically just take one of your
machines from you is that not true
so yeah that is true is that they could
that they could shut down your machine
there's
and i think it depends upon the cloud
providers i think one of them will
only turn it off um won't turn off for
the first hour
and the other might turn off sooner um
but if
the way this works with the um
since we're using kubernetes and gcp and
aws batch if a machine goes away
elastic blast will realize that and
decide that this machine has failed
and start a new machine to replace it
so in principle it should work
should continue to work it would need to
could be a problem if the um you know if
for example that no preemptable or no
spot instances are available
but it sounds like this is so it sounds
like elastic blast takes this into
account and and will it's flexible
enough to deal with that so that's
interesting yeah
yeah so it's it's resilient and mostly
i'd say it's resilient because we're
leveraging kubernetes and aws batch that
um want to be resilient against
stuff going
you know stuff happening in the cloud
okay and there's a question about an
integrating elastic blast into a next
flow pipeline um and christian did
answer that in the in the
questions pod uh i don't know if you
have any comments that christian says he
doesn't see why you couldn't do it but
we haven't tried it
no we we haven't tried it but i i think
that's a great idea
if somebody has an example maybe we can
go down to the example page or something
um maybe we can do an example ourselves
so that's um
that would be great to hear about
okay well i think that's um everything
that we have in the question spot for
now so
thanks everybody for coming i'll go
ahead and end the webinar for everybody
and we'll talk to you next time thanks
everyone thank you okay bye